ministre votre gouvernement vient de
fermer la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim et vous aurez ainsi tenu la
promesse de françois hollande fait aux
plus radicaux des écologistes cette
fermeture est un gâchis écologique
économique et humain et à cette belle
occasion surprise deux ministres
improvisent une visite madame bornes et
madame wagon pour annoncer qu'après deux
ans et demi de travail pour relever le
défi de l'après nucléaire
un comité interministériel sur a créé un
commissaire à la reconversion sera
désigné et un technocentre pourraient
être créés mais sont les halles sont les
allemands inconcevable
voilà comment votre gouvernement gère
une reconversion et pour le volet fiscal
du fn gir pour rappel la collectivité va
devoir payer 2,9 millions d'euros alors
qu'elle n'a plus de recettes fiscales et
bien un groupe de travail sera créé la
belle affaire
tout aurait pu être anticipé rien ne l'a
été ce territoire des sacrifiés au delà
du territoire ces décisions dessert les
intérêts de notre pays
d'abord c'est l'argent du contribuable
qui va servir à indemniser edf à hauteur
de 400 millions d'euros
ensuite il faudra bien compenser cette
perte de production d'électricité ainsi
nous devons allègrement apporter
plusieurs millions de tonnes de fioul et
de gaz qui généreront un déficit
commercial de 2 milliards d'euros par an
dois je vous rappeler que l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire est en moyenne 80
fois moins productrice de ce2 co2 que
celle du charbon est 40 fois moins que
celle du gaz ainsi la fermeture de
fessenheim va se traduire par l'émission
de 10 millions de tonnes de co2
supplémentaires par an mais alors tous
les discours sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et les accords
de paris vous allez me répondre
éolien ou solaire mais il faudrait
multiplier par quatre les chances
d'éolien et solaire pour atteindre la
cible affiché en 2035 par le
gouvernement or madame borgne a dénoncé
le 18 février dernier au sénat un
développement anarchique des éoliennes
en france faut pour you see me répondent
biométhane mais là encore les objectifs
sont très loin des enjeux réels
le nucléaire français présente un
avantage compétitif sur le plan
économique et sur le plan
environnemental
c'est le giec qui le dit pensez vous que
la situation de notre
au pays et de nos concitoyens soient si
florissante que l'on puisse priver la
france d'un ses avantages mais si vous
voulez